Сільська ідилія в Бранденбурзі, за 80 кілометрів від Берліна.
Тут мешкають 130 людей. При цьому вони виробляють стільки енергії,
що вистачило б кільком тисячам.
Фельдгайм став першим селом у Німеччині, яке цілковито забезпечує себе струмом
і теплом самостійно. Вже 12 років місцева громада не залежить від викопних джерел енергії.
Усе почалося 1995 року зі спорудження чотирьох вітряків.
Ініціатором втілення проєкту тоді став Міхаель Рашеманн.
Зрештою завдяки перемовинам про це у селі серед мешканців
настільки зросли очікування, що у певний момент вони сказали:
ні-ні, якщо ви хочете тим, що є у нас в Фельдгаймі, струм і тепло виробляти,
то й ми хочемо щось з цього мати.
Наразі вже 55 вітряків у місцині виробляють струм для понад 55 тисяч домогосподарств.
Але і це ще не все. З 2008 року біогазова установка у селі виробляє
ще більше струму й тепла - з гною, житньої крупи й кукурудзяного силосу.
Таким чином Фельдгайм щороку заощаджує цілих 260 тисяч літрів мазуту.
Ситуація, звісно, була така, що ми отримували погані ринкові ціни
за нашу сільгосппродукцію, яку зазвичай продавали: жито чи кукурудзу.
Водночас федеральний уряд встановив фіксований тариф на струм,
вироблений біогазовими установками. Тож це, звісно, заохотило нас, аграріїв,
сказати: інвестуймо в таку біогазову установку,
аби у нас було постійне джерело прибутків для наших працівників.
Як і у випадку з вітряками, долучитися та мати зиск від проєкту,
який спочатку опалював лише кілька промислових будівель, сауну та свинарник,
захотіли більшість мешканців села.
У Фельдгаймі це викликало позитивні реакції.
Одразу низка мешканців захотіли приєднатися до тепломережі.
Потім підготували плани і згодом, коли ці плани представили,
вони дійсно переконали майже всіх мешканців Фельдгайма, які захотіли доєднатися.
Слід зауважити, що саме в Німеччині ще 1990 року було ухвалено перший у світі закон,
який регулював постачання струму з відновлювальних джерел у громадську мережу.
Таким чином держава легалізувала присутність виробників "зеленого" струму на енергоринку.
У той час це були здебільшого малі підприємства, яким неабияк ускладнювали життя
великі постачальники електроенергії.
Ті, зокрема, відмовлялися надавати новачкам доступ до своїх енергомереж.
Саме з такою проблемою зіткнулися й мешканці Фельдгайма.
Тож їм довелося розбудувати нову власну електро- і тепломережу.
Місцевий постачальник відмовився надати в користування сільським виробникам
струму й тепла свою мережу. Вони просто не хотіли.
Мовляв, це маленьке галльське село, навіть якщо їм усе вдасться,
ми не дозволимо себе підпорядковувати.
Тоді селяни взяли справу в свої руки, і тепер їм є чим похвалитися.
Ціна нафти мене в останні роки насправді майже не цікавила.
Хіба що коли доводиться платити відносно високу ціну за дизель на заправці.
В очікуванні прийдешньої зими і можливого дефіциту газу в Німеччині
мешканці Фельдгайма не переймаються. Бургомістр не приховує гордості.
Я міг би відкинутися у кріслі і сказати: енергетичний переворот завершено, усе.
Однак ми так не хочемо. Ми хочемо показати, що можна організувати
власні цикли виробництва енергії, які роблять нас більш незалежними
від усіх путіних і шейхів цього світу.
Тим, хто хоче наслідувати приклад німецького Фельдгайма, звісно,
варто запастися терпінням і часом: селянам знадобилося майже два десятиліття,
щоб стати енергетично незалежною громадою.
Ще одна важлива складова, наголошує бургомістр, - довіра між усіма учасниками процесу.
Крім того, готовність брати на себе відповідальність та спільне бачення мети.
Усе це дозволило Фельдгайму фактично стати взірцем того,
що екологічне та самодостатнє енергопостачання
забезпечує водночас політичну свободу.